jason jones is a former texas border
security captain who joins us live time
from the southern border as he did last
night
jason jones thanks so much for coming on
we asked you last night for
the latest on what you're seeing and
hearing down there and i would i would
ask that again tonight what does it look
like
yeah yeah tucker thanks for having me
it's good to be with you
tonight well we were in roma texas this
morning and for the viewers roma
is a small community that lies between
laredo and mcallen texas right in the
center
and we were sitting on the bluffs at 7
40 this morning when a large gun battle
broke out
now across from roma texas is a small
community called miguel aleman
that community has been embattled
between two cartels for the last two
years cartel de gaffo also known as the
gulf cartel
and cartel del noreste known as the los
zetas by many
those two cartels have been battling for
two years and we caught that gun battle
this morning
remarkable and we're seeing infants
gunfire gun battle okay can you turn
real quick so they can hear
oh yeah there it goes we're still alive
not a rock texas no that
yeah that's a that's a great point and
that's where we talk about that what's
happening at our border is
much more in depth than just the
immigration layer and i don't want to
just say
just because it's a serious issue but
it's important that the american people
know that what is happening down here is
much broader in scope than just people
crossing our border
and you know these gun battles are
happening when we were we were
talking with cbp officials state and
local law enforcement
they're hearing these gun battles
between two and four times a week
and in december we were down there with
lara logan and her team
and we caught an hour and a half long
gun battle and tucker i want you to know
i'm talking everything from 40
millimeter grenades
50 caliber belt fed machine guns armored
vehicles
these things are massive and it goes
really to the breadth of how the cartels
have evolved and gone through quantum
leaps
and changes but this is what is
occurring at our southern border
and you know it's much bigger than just
an immigration issue down here
apparently the new president has moved
additional u.s troops to syria
is resisting pulling american troops out
of afghanistan
do you see american troops on our border
as a war rages right across the river
i do and it's time we we need to do a
lot more in
in that arena the cartels
are not just a u.s mexico problem i
think
the way most people see them they have
gone through massive changes and give
you an example of that sinaloa cartel is
in 54 countries around the world
cartel jalisco new generation is in over
48 now
so you know this is a global problem and
we have continued to do the same thing
hoping for a different result building
cases on these folks as they have
evolved all over the world and begin
using military-grade weapons and
tradecraft that we're seeing you know
terrorist organizations around the world
using
and that's why we've been calling to
designate them as foreign terrorist
organizations
and i i just want to stress that doesn't
mean we go to war with the cartels but
what it does mean
is that we use the tools of national
power to finally
focus on them yeah and to protect their
country i mean
these are these cartels back down the
entire mexican army
so i mean these are sophisticated forces
obviously jason i appreciate your
your report tonight from the border
thank you